peter what's up brother how are you
doing i've been struggling with some
news i found out a couple years ago
that my mom has actually been
panhandling
um so we've talked about it but it's
still you know
i guess it's still waiting on me a
couple years later
have you talked to your mom about it
yeah um
i mean she's struggled with money her
whole life you know since i can remember
and a friend of mine um said that she
they saw her you know with a like a
cardboard sign
asking for money you know yeah um so we
did
we did talk to her about it and she
admitted to it um but said that you know
she was just
in a hole and uh needed some quick money
to get out of it
um we my her sister my aunt right so she
has a little bit
of of this probably the best financial
situation of the family
even offered she said okay how much do
you need to get out of this hole
and was willing to you know write a
check right there but my mother refused
and then completely shut down
doesn't want to discuss it anymore you
know
hey can i just tell you man that sucks
i'm sorry
i'm trying to wrap my head around like
me and your situation man that's hard to
see
hard to hear huh yeah
i mean i think i'm struggling more
because like
she's she's always been very generous
but now i have my own kids
yeah so she'll wanna she'll want to give
my kids like a christmas present or a
birthday present
yeah and the only thing i'm thinking is
that that money came from her begging
um man there's a couple of things here
number one
uh how old are you man i'm in my 40s
okay how old your mom uh 60s
so is there any plan for 65 70 75 is
there anything down the road
um for her i don't think so give me
social security any sort of well i guess
that yes
but i know she's she's worked her whole
life and then
right into her 60s her job was
outsourced so she was kind of like
forced into early retirement
yeah um and hasn't been able to find
another job since then
okay so it's been a couple years and i
as far as i know she's getting
you know social security but i i don't
know of any kind of
you know 401k or any other you know
retirement plans
and um so do you have i haven't spoke to
her about that do you have brothers and
sisters
i have a an older brother yeah have you
all sat down and had this conversation
yet
is he is he trustworthy in that way i'm
about it but he's not
he doesn't seem as concerned about it as
i am you know he's
he's about his mom panhandling right
yeah
yeah unfortunately he's what would the
resp i'm trying to put my head around i
don't want to throw shade at your
brother yo but like what would you
what would you say to that look all that
sucks dude how's the game like how do
you respond
pretty much i mean no i i said you know
we need to get her help we need to find
out what kind of you know situation
she's in you know i i
i'm like this can't be her retirement
plan yeah
um so but he he just says you know well
she's going to do what she's got to do
kind of kind of an attitude you know
well hey here's the sucky part he's
right you know what i mean yeah
um kind of like the last caller i'm not
going down without a fight but
he's right um man
i wish i had more for you here's here's
the
well let me ask you this before i start
rattling off here
um you said this has been bothering you
for a few years walk me through what's
been going on in your heart mind for the
last few years
well yeah i mean you know just just the
image
of my mom you know holding a cardboard
sign right right
um it's very painful so have you have
you gone to get involved have you driven
up and said get in this car
and taking her to get pancakes somewhere
and just be like what is going on man
no what is what has stopped you from
doing that
i don't know that's i guess that's a
good good advice
i mean that's that's square one if i
know my mom's on the side of
a street corner brother i'm gonna tell
you right now again i'm not hating on
you
i'm just telling you i'm gonna get in
the car and go get my mom out the street
um have you ever sat her down in a
not in a fight but just in a hey i'm
coming to hang out with your mom and
just said hey what's going on
i mean we tried when we first got that
news
and you know and she just i don't want
to talk about this anymore you know
she kind of just shut everything down um
so every every family's different every
mom is different so
um i'm known for having a pretty direct
personality okay
but if i find out that someone i love my
mom
just trying to put myself in your shoes
and she says i don't want to talk about
it
i'm going to say i don't care what you
want to talk about my mom is not going
to be panhandling that's not a solution
to life
so we are going to talk about this would
she say screw you and get up and walk
out or would she
put her head down and be so grateful
that somebody punched through that
wall she's got and then
said what do we do next like what would
her response be
i think based on the last time we spoke
about it she'd walk away
okay here's what i'm not able to do if
i'm you
i'm not able to know that i did every
what's the worst that's gonna happen
she's gonna be right back where she's at
right
right and so are you married right now
yeah
okay so here's what i would do if i was
you um
number one i wanna just say dude i'm
glad that you still love your mom
you still care for that tells me that
you've got something in your heart
that's not going to sleep right until
you know your mom's sleeping right and
that means you're a good man
and um so good for you
i do think you've got some action ahead
of you asap okay
um i think you need to get with your
wife and set up whatever boundaries are
going to be boundaries
as if mom said okay would you let her
move in
if mom said okay would you help
supplement rent if mom said okay
fill in the blank get your boundaries
firm and it may be none of those things
like we don't have the room for her to
move in we don't have any spare change
in our house
um that's not something we can do cool
but get with your wife and set up some
really firm boundaries
and then you gotta get on the horn and
to get your brother and say hey i'm
gonna have an intervention with mom
we heard about it again that she's out
begging on the streets again
and we're not gonna let mom do that and
if he blows you off he blows you off but
you know at least i invited him into
this conversation which you don't want
to have some hardcore conversation
and then him find out a couple months
later and then be like oh you just left
me out of it bro like you know what i
mean make you the bad guy on that deal
so invite him in say hey i'm going on
this day at this time and we're
we're done with this and then be real
direct with your mom tell that you love
her and that this isn't safe
and you want to come up with some other
solutions whether it's getting her
connected to regional or local services
or whether it is helping her find a job
whether it's giving her a place to stay
whether it's giving her food money
whatever that happens to be however you
can help support her
and then at the end of the day you'll at
least be able to put your head on a
pillow not knowing everything's okay
but knowing i did everything that i
could do and i would also bring your
kids along on this deal too
because i want them to see their dad
going to the ends of the earth for his
mom
okay okay and i want them to
love grandma and to know grandma and
here's another thing
um i'm gonna do this i want you to stay
on the line
kelly is gonna give you a year
subscription to ramsay plus which is
all of the financial tools for my from
the guy
my old my boss here dave ramsey i was
gonna say my old man he's not my dad
kind of is but not really he signs my
paychecks
no my dad's my dad but it's got
everything from the financial peace
university classes in it to the
the apps all the stuff and this is
starting from square one
and you're going to be able to use that
with your mom if she's interested if
she's not
then you can use it for your family if
she's interested
this will walk her through step one and
i don't care how old you are how young
you are
it's never too late to say starting
today i'm gonna follow this plan and
you know dave ramsey he's helped
millions and millions of people get out
of debt
this is bigger than that he just teach
people how to handle their money which
means he teaches people how to handle
and live lives with intentionality right
how to be whole
and so this is i'm gonna i'm gonna give
you what i can right
put a tool in your hand and you may have
to call local services you may
i don't know whatever that is but i'm
not going down i'm not gonna sleep at
night knowing my mom's doing that
without at least
knowing i did everything i could to get
my mom off the street
everything i could i'm gonna bunk my
kids up for a season i'm going to
call my brother i'm going to call her
church i'm going to figure something out
until she says i don't want that man i
don't want to be in any of this stuff i
like i can make good money
doing what i'm doing forget you get out
of my life
and that'll suck but at least you'll
know
right at least you'll know thank you for
that call brother thank you for your
heart
um get involved and get active and then
call me back email me back let me know
how those conversations go how those
plans go and
man